is on lockdown i'm on my way wait aren't
you at the dentist yeah i left it's fine
it's a new hygienist and to be honest
your scraping technique was a joke we
have 14 minutes to find a hacker you're
not gonna get back in time but everybody
else is there right i mean it seems
weird to have this big thing happen
without me we talked about this amy you
have an unhealthy fear of missing out on
work you have foam out this isn't bomo
it's not like i'm freaking out or
anything out of my way you all [ __ ]
this time is mine
i'll be there in 10 minutes i love you
don't solve it without me i got the keys
let's go
being generous
hands that was too slow decided to walk
it's nice to take a little stroll you're
clearly running at full speed whatever
how's it going there not great we still
haven't found the hacker oh super i mean
oh no is anybody full mowing of course
not big time
okay i gotta go babe we're headed to
holt don't you dare hang up on me i have
partners i hate to say but maybe it's
time we start thinking about erasing the
server no not until the last possible
minute what else can you do i've been
trying to pinpoint him i've been making
my way through the server sockets trying
to determine which port he's plugged
into what's going on i can't hear
anything turn me around i'm missing
everything
part of the team what's up team is
sergeant santiago suffering from foamal
no
what's happening i think the hacker just
opened the holding cell
i promise i'll try honestly i just don't
see it changing oh move oh
oh no why are you outside is it over do
you catch a hacker no i have a personal
thing that's more important to me oh
yeah work-life balance i have that too
sorry i can't tell it's me
come on come on come on
got it
what
time check five minutes ten seconds it's
over don't say that we'll never get the
garlic red toast in a time we can and we
will oh we'll set the oven to 500 are
you insane it'll burn we're wrapping
foil the foil will stick to the cheese
it's a risk we'll have to take
that
hey you made it i finally got all the
lambda news back into holding go on
lambda news doesn't matter i'll read
your notes later i didn't take any notes
what the hell jake do you even love me
says the woman who never once sent me
flowers never mind yeah we still haven't
found the hacker but the cyber guy is
getting close okay let's check in with
alt
hold on to him girl he seems pretty
sweet and you guys are like both sevens
come on i'm sergeant santiago i'm sure
these guys have told you all about me
already long story short nothing happens
around here without me i don't know
anything about computers none of us do
and knox could tell that so he knew that
we wouldn't catch on if he just made
stuff up what if the reason we can't
find the hacker is because there is no
hacker but why would knox lie about that
what if he doesn't actually care what's
on the lakme servers maybe his real goal
is to just trick holt into erasing all
the servers he might just be trying to
delete some evidence
so you think he's a criminal oh my god
we have to go right now
i know how i know knox
he's the guy from the security footage
in the avery street murder you sure yes
he shaved his beard but it's definitely
him
we have less than a minute call hold max
is right next to him he'll hear
everything here i'll text him
look i don't get it hope was about to
erase the servers if that's what knox
wanted why did he stop him and say the
hacker was in room 103. i don't know
maybe to get rid of us no
to get rid of you the second you showed
up in holt's office he sent us away and
the holding cell doors they opened when
i walked in with amy on my phone he must
have known that she would recognize him
knox you're pointing a gun at an nypd
captain have you really thought this
through this is not my fault you were
supposed to be at the dentist what how
did you
you called me he called me he said he
had a tip for the officer in charge of
the avery murder i said i could meet any
time except for this morning because of
the dentist i had it all planned out
guess you didn't count on my phone now
yeah that's right it's grimly picking a
weird time but i'm glad you're finally
owning it
you